[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARL OSIPOV: All right,
good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Carl, and this is Evan.
And I hope you're all here
for the BigQuery Nested
and Repeated Fields,
Dig Deeper into Data.
Sounds like a very long title
for the end of the long day,
so we'll do our best to
keep you guys energized.
And we have a wonderful
presentation prepared for you.
Just a couple of
words about ourselves.
My name is Carl Osipov.
I'm a staff program
manager at Google Cloud.
And I help Google Cloud
customers and partners
succeed with our offering by
getting trained and certified.
And, Evan--
EVAN JONES: I'm Evan Jones.
I've been teaching SQL
for going on 10, 15 years.
And honestly, using BigQuery
is an absolute blast.
And hopefully you'll see through
some of the demos here today.
And if you'd like to
learn more, there's
a lot of Coursera courses
that we do a lot of.
I'm on the training
and curriculum team
that we have as well.
So if you're not sick of
seeing my mug after today,
you're welcome to
watch eight hours of me
teach about BigQuery
ML on Coursera.
CARL OSIPOV: All right, awesome.
And if you need to
find out more about us,
just feel free to reach out.
Our e-mails are really
simple, first name, last name
@Google.com.
So here's what this
session is about.
And really, I want to make
this session about all of you.
So I have some questions
for you to start with.
First of all, if
you are currently
analyzing data that's maybe
stored in formats like JSON,
JavaScript, Object
Notation, or XML,
could you please just
throw your hand up
if you're analyzing
this type of data?
Very good.
So maybe about half of you.
And please keep
holding your hand.
So for those of you who
are holding your hand up,
how many of you are analyzing
that data using SQL?
All right, so we're down
to maybe about a third.
And how many of you
are analyzing that data
using SQL on BigQuery?
All right, so now we're
down to about a fifth.
So I think, for vast majority
of you, a lot of the content
here in this presentation is
going to be really interesting.
So I'll explain this concept
of semi-structured data
that might be new
to many of you.
And then I'll help you
grow your SQL skills
to help you understand how
to use features of SQL 2011,
like arrays and structured
type, to analyze
semi-structured data.
So I think most of you
have seen BigQuery by now,
so I'm not going to go
too deep into BigQuery.
But I'll give a brief
refresher on this offering
from Google Cloud.
And then I'll show
you how BigQuery
can help you tap into this
semi-structured data, which
is extremely important.
And we're going to
have a lot of demos.
Actually, we'll have a lot of
live coding in this session,
so don't expect this
to be a sales pitch.
This is going to be
a lot of fun examples
you can take away
from this session
and use on your own projects.
And ultimately, I know
it's the end of the day,
so we want to keep
you guys energized
and hopefully come up with some
really good questions for us.
So my question
for you, are there
anybody here in the audience who
are analyzing petabytes of data
today?
Could I just see
a show of hands?
Oh, I think we
have single digits.
And at a first glance,
right, petabyte of data,
that may sound absurdly large.
In fact, if you try to
download a petabyte of data
over a cell phone
connection, over 4G,
it will take about 27 years
to download all of that.
And I am dating myself
a little bit here.
But if you take those old floppy
disks, the 5 and 1/4 inch,
and try to stack them
up on top of one another
to have a petabyte
worth of data capacity,
that's going to be more than
12 Empire State buildings.
It's over 100
Libraries of Congress,
or every tweet ever
recorded more than 50 times.
So sounds like a lot.
But I'd like you to think
about a petabyte of data
slightly differently.
If you are in the genomics
field, well, petabyte of data
is just about two
micrograms of DNA,
if you try to sequence that DNA.
Or from Google's standpoint,
a petabyte of data
is how much Google
gets every day.
That's the amount of video
that Google gets uploaded
into YouTube on a daily basis.
And at this point, you
can say, look, Carl,
I don't do genomics, or
my company is not Google.
So it's not relevant to us.
But I challenge you to
think about petabytes
of data in the following way.
So think about application
servers or web servers.
Many companies, many
projects out there
have hundreds of these servers.
200 servers is not
a large number.
And if you think about
these application servers,
just generating log data, just
logging maybe website visitors
at 50 entries a second, if you
don't have a petabyte of data
now, in three years, with
these 200 application servers,
you will have a petabyte
of data to analyze.
So the point is, even if
a vast majority of you
are not analyzing petabytes
of data today, you will soon.
So what is that data?
And I'm sure many of you know
that the studies have shown
that 80% to 90% of that
data, the data in the world,
is unstructured data.
But I think if you here
at the BigQuery session,
you've probably have had some
experience with SQL, with using
BigQuery, and you're comfortable
with structured data, the data
that's organized into
rows and columns, data
with a relational schema.
And that's what you
want to analyze.
So it seems like a
challenge to think
about all this unstructured
data, all these images,
natural language text, videos,
and think about how you
can get value out of that data.
Well, yes, it's
impossible, really,
to analyze unstructured
data using SQL.
But there's another very
important category of data
that I want to draw
your attention to.
And that's semi-structured data.
So if you want to think
about semi-structured data,
think about data in
a format like JSON,
or XML, or even some
key value databases.
It's the data where you may
have some relational schema.
You can think about
parts of JSON objects
in terms of the schema that has
strings, or integers, or dates.
But at the same time,
it has some data
that doesn't really fit into
relational, traditional rows
and columns formats.
Think arrays, or
think about key value
pairs, of dictionaries in JSON.
So it seems like there's
an interesting category
in the middle between
unstructured and structured
data types.
So it seems like it might be
interesting in some cases.
Are there any practical
examples of this kind of data?
Well, I just wanted to mention
this recent announcement.
This was announced back
in May of this year.
Twitter, the social
networking company,
actually decided to migrate
their infrastructure over
to Google Cloud.
And think about the
contents of these tweets.
This is a perfect example
of semi-structured data.
Just look at the
tweet right here.
It has natural language text.
But at the same time,
this kind of data
contains embedded at mentions.
This contains hyperlinks.
And it also has some
structured information
with pointers to graphic.
It has dates, et cetera.
So this is a perfect
example of a kind
of data that exists in
a semi-structured format
that many companies
may want to analyze.
And now that Twitter is
moving to Google Cloud,
they'd be able to
use Google Cloud
capabilities like BigQuery
to analyze this type of data.
And if you're still
skeptical, I just
wanted to give you a few
more concrete examples.
In preparing for this
talk, I actually went out
and thought about the
developer activity
around semi-structured data.
So the first place
that I went to
was GitHub, the source
code repository.
And I went out and tried to
analyze the GitHub commits
or file changes to various
structured and semi-structured
data formats.
So this is what I came up with.
I actually looked at
just the top five formats
that you see listed
on the slide.
And if you're
wondering why top five,
it's because other
formats like DDLs for SQL
and others actually
resulted in too few
commits to make a significant
bar on this chart.
So this is one
interesting data point.
You can see over 100
million commits for JSON
relative to about 10 million
for CSV, which is commonly
used for structured data.
And at this point, you
could say, so what?
All right, so this
is GitHub commits.
On one hand, GitHub is not
really a data repository.
And in the same time,
developers often
use JSON and XML as their
configuration files, right,
something that they would
change all the time.
And that's fair.
So I went out and looked at
other sites for developers.
The first one I looked
at was Stack Overflow.
And you'll notice
a pattern, right?
So the similar type
of proportion exists.
If you look at the
semi-structured data
formats like JSON
and XML, they receive
significantly more
questions than CSV
and various variants of SQL.
So in this case, I actually
looked at the questions
for DDL formats as well.
So that's just two data points.
But if you go and look
at other data sources,
like the very well-known Hacker
News, social media website,
a similar pattern exists.
In fact, I went out and
looked at Google Trends,
Google's own data repository.
And there's roughly
the same proportion.
If you compare the
developer activity
around structured and
semi-structured data formats,
about 80% to 90%
of that activity
happens around JSON, XML,
YAML, the semi-structured data
formats, as opposed to
structured data formats
that I lumped here
together with CSV, TSV,
tab-separated formats, SQL,
DDL, and even Parquet and Avro.
So the point is, there
is something there.
There's a valuable set of data
that exists that developers
are working with.
But you need to ask
yourself, are you
getting insights
out of this data?
Clearly it's important.
This amount of data is growing.
But what can you do about it?
It seems like, since
it's semi-structured,
traditional SQL is not
really the right tool.
And this is what I want to--
that's the point
where I want to change
your opinion in this session.
So how many of you are
first timers to BigQuery?
How many of you have never
heard of BigQuery before today?
Oh, my god.
This is the first time I
think I am seeing single digit
hands going up in this room.
So it looks like most
of you know BigQuery.
You know it's a
petabyte-scale data warehouse
available from Google Cloud.
It can get you
results in seconds.
And some of the reasons
why it's so fast
is using this columnar-based
storage format
that, behind the scenes, is
supported by a file system that
automatically shards the data
and makes it available to you
as a BigQuery user at
extremely high throughput rates
with very low latency.
And what you'll
look at in a moment
is the support for two types
of data structures in BigQuery
known as arrays and struts.
And what I'll show you is
that both of these data types
are part of SQL 2011 standard.
So if you are already
a SQL guru but have not
got a chance to work with these
two types of data structures,
I think you will find a
lot of interesting examples
in this session.
So one thing you need
to know about BigQuery
is that it consists
of two parts.
There's BigQuery storage,
that is the data warehouse
piece that maintains,
warehouses your data,
and then there's the
BigQuery analysis engine
that takes your SQL
statements and uses those SQL
statements to analyze data.
And what's great about
BigQuery is that, first of all,
it supports various types of
data formats and data input
sources.
For example, you can
get data into BigQuery
from something like Google
Analytics, Firebase,
other services on Google
Cloud, like Cloud Datastore,
and have that data reside
inside of BigQuery storage.
And another thing that
is great about BigQuery
is that it allows you to use the
BigQuery analysis engine to run
SQL statements against
data that resides
outside of BigQuery storage.
So for example, you
can use BigQuery
to analyze data in something
like Cloud Storage buckets
or in Cloud Bigtable.
And BigQuery is used by
customers throughout the world.
In fact, at this point,
BigQuery supports
exabytes of data for
Google Cloud customers.
Now, let's wrap up with
the introductory part
of the presentation and shift
into something more technical.
So what I'd like to
do next is show you
an example of analyzing
semi-structured data
with BigQuery.
And here's what I'll show you.
Suppose I want to build an
analysis engine to find out,
what do developers care about?
Developers are early adopters.
They sort of foresee trends.
So what I'd like
to be able to do
is get data from
the website known
as Hacker News, the
social media website,
figure out what a
developer is talking about,
and then use that
information to help
me guide my decisions about
which technologies to learn.
And before this
session, I actually
went out to Hacker News,
and I used their APIs
that happened to be JSON-based
APIs, JavaScript Object
Notation-based APIs, to download
some sample data on my laptop.
And what I'll do next is
import that data into BigQuery
here on stage.
Now, the way that
I'll import this data
is that I'll take
this route shown
on the screen with letter A.
So imagine I have my JSON file.
And I'll use the web
UI that you see here
to import this data into
the BigQuery storage.
Now, I can use the web UI.
I can also use
command-line interface
from BigQuery, known as bq tool.
I can even use BigQuery
application programming
interfaces, APIs, to do that.
Now, that's the approach that
I'll take here during the demo.
If you're planning to
import data into BigQuery
in production, please--
I really ask you, please--
don't use this approach.
And here's why.
If you're trying to
import data into BigQuery
using this direct
route, there are
many things that can go wrong.
One of them, if you're
using a browser,
browsers have limitations
on the sizes of files
that you can upload.
Browsers can crash.
The network connections
can get interrupted.
So if you're thinking
about importing data
into BigQuery storage
and production, what
I'd like you to do is
follow this route shown
with letter B on the slide.
So here's how it works.
You're going to take a
tool known as gsutil.
It's a command-line utility.
You will take your data and
copy this data into something
called Google Cloud Storage.
And the great thing
about this gsutil tool
is that it will be a
full-tolerant upload
for your data, meaning
that gsutil will actually
resume data transfers if there
is a failure in the network
connections.
Gsutil will actually
take checkpoints
to make sure that it
doesn't have to re-upload
the entire data set.
It only re-uploads the changes
after the network connection.
And one of the coolest
things about gsutil
is that it supports
multithreaded uploading, which
means that you can control
how much bandwidth you
may want to allocate
to this gsutil tool.
And then after you moved
your data via gsutil
into Google Cloud
Storage, then your data
is inside of Google
Cloud, and you
can use the rest of these tools
that you see on the screen
to get your data into BigQuery.
All right, so that's
enough with an overview.
Let's switch over to
the demo, and I'll
show you how this works.
So as you can see right now,
I'm looking at the BigQuery user
interface.
This should look very
familiar to most of you.
And notice that here I
have my BigQuery project
with this long name,
but we're going
to call it a Qwiklabs project.
So to import data
into this project,
I need to create something
called a data set.
A data set is simply a container
for the various data tables
that I have inside of BigQuery.
So I am uploading
Hacker News data.
Let me just call it HN,
short for Hacker News.
I'm not going to specify
the location for this data.
I'll leave it unspecified.
But if I wanted to, I
could have set up data
residency for this data set
in the US, EU, or Tokyo.
OK, so now I have
this new data set.
Let's actually go
ahead and create
a new table in this data set.
So I'll click Create New Table.
And after I close the editor
on the right-hand side,
you'll notice that, on the
right side of my screen,
I have this option to create
a table from source data.
And as I pointed out moments
ago, just for this demo,
I'll upload a file into this
table from my local file
system.
And this file is going
to be a JSON document.
If you're wondering what
it looks like, remember,
this is the data that I
received from the Hacker News
website via the APIs.
So I cleaned it up a little bit.
And if you look
at the data here,
you can see that it's
typical JSON object.
So I have a date, and
then I have these stories.
And now this starts looking
very different from most
of relational tables out there.
Notice that I have
a single date.
And now within these stories,
I have array of values.
These are titles of
articles, the number
of times they have
been uploaded,
the score, the URL to these
articles, and so forth.
So this is what the
data looks like.
Let's go ahead and try to
upload this into BigQuery.
So I'm going to
do a file upload.
I'm going to choose
my JSON document.
And lets call this destination
table as HN for Hacker News.
And since this is
from December 2008,
I'll use 2008 as the suffix.
Now, I could have specified
the schema manually.
But here I'll trust
BigQuery to figure out
the scheme of this JSON
document automatically.
Let's go ahead and
click Create Table.
And when I do this,
BigQuery creates
something known as a job.
So in this case, the
job happens to be
to load the data inside
of the BigQuery table.
I can see that the
job is complete.
So let's actually take
a look at this table.
Let's preview the
contents of this table.
And this should look familiar.
Notice that I have a
single row of data.
Here's the URL to a
story from Hacker News.
Here's the score,
the number of times
that it has been
uploaded, its title,
and then there's the date.
Now, if you've used traditional
relational databases
in the past, this should
start to look weird.
What happened to this date?
I have all these
values with the title,
but now they're
blanks for the date.
Where did the date go?
And notice that I have many of
these titles for a single date.
So how do I analyze this?
Let's take a look at the schema.
Maybe, yes, it has some hints.
Well, this looks familiar.
There's a date.
It's nullable, so date
is a standard SQL type.
There are strings, integers.
All of that looks familiar.
But now there are these stories.
And if you've never
seen this before,
records repeated,
what are these?
So I've been doing
SQL for a while,
but now I'm totally confused.
So I don't know what to do.
And at this point, I'd like to
introduce my colleague, Evan,
back on stage.
He is going to give us the
tools to better analyze
this record-repeated
strangeness in the schema.
EVAN JONES: Thanks, Carl.
Cool.
So whenever you
have any problems
with nested and repeated
fields, just call me.
That's the solution,
end of demo.
No, I'm kidding.
This, I'll say it blew me away.
So I've been working on
a SQL for 10, 15 years.
And before I was smart
enough, as Carl mentioned,
to go into the schema
and look for that,
I was looking at the data.
And the first thing that,
exactly is Carl mentioned,
you have one row.
And for me being
a structured data
guy in the background
as a data analyst,
scrolling over and
seeing the date
here and what I saw
it was null records,
I kind of lost my mind.
I'm like, oh, this is
really, really weird.
Even still, you have what
you thought was one field,
but it has a dot in it.
You've got stories dot title.
You've got stories dot score.
So it almost looks like it's
two different tables in one.
You've got dates, and
you've got articles,
and you have the details
all in one place.
So that's-- we're going to
get into the magic as we work
through some of these SQL
queries that you're going
to see.
But the real exciting
part about it
for me personally, even if
your data isn't in this format
already, it could be.
And that's the really,
really fun part,
is because, in a traditional
relational database
sense, normally you might
have multiple different tables
stored in multiple different
places in a technical term
that we called normalization.
And that's great for
relational databases.
But BigQuery doesn't
operate that way.
And you get a huge, huge
potential performance boost
by bringing your data
together, potentially
in what I like to call a
pre-joined or a nested way.
So let's run through
a bunch of queries.
And I've got some cool
questions for you guys, too.
Unfortunately, I wish I had
some swag or something like that
to throw out in the crowd, but
you'll just have to make do.
So first and foremost, if
you're familiar with SQL,
you've probably seen
a lot select star.
And looking at some of these
might be just a little bit
baffling, but stick with it.
So the first thing we want
to do is you can actually
create array types.
This is a nice, booming voice.
You can create array
types directly into SQL.
So what I'm going to do, I'm
still in the BigQuery web UI.
If you didn't know it already,
if you actually highlight
a portion of the query--
I'm hitting
Command-E on the Mac.
But you can actually execute
just a partial statement
of the SQL.
So I've got a long
SQL statement that I'm
going to walk through
and execute each portion,
as you see.
So I've got an array
that I want to create.
As you saw in the image
a little bit earlier,
I have four different
fruits that I
want to fill into my
little array basket.
So I'm saying this is
going to be an array.
An array, again,
is just going to be
a collection of those items
that share a singular data type.
So that's the critical
part, is that I'm saying,
hey, everything that's going
to be in this collection
is going to be a string.
So arrays have to share
the single data type.
That's going to come back
in one of the key points
that we talk about later.
So as you saw on the
results, again, if--
I haven't really worked a
lot with arrays and BigQuery.
This might look super strange.
And the really cool part is,
if you hover over the type,
you see, hey, not only
is it a string in there,
but it's repeated.
So that's how you get your
repeated data in there.
Or you have four, what
seemingly looks like four,
rows with one row here.
So the first time I saw
that, I was like, OK.
Let's see how far
we can take this.
All right, well, do I need
to necessarily specify
the string that you saw
in brackets there earlier?
No, I don't.
BigQuery smart enough
to recognize that,
hey, if you're
passing in things that
look like they're
in string notation,
sure, I'll interpret
it as a string for you.
As you see here, it's
still going to be a string.
All right, well, what
are some cool things
that can do once you have
your data inside of arrays
or you're accessing a data
set that already has arrays?
And by the way, the reason why
we're creating these arrays,
normally, if you
had a field, you
could just have the
field name in here.
But we just wanted to show
you the special sauce is
what's behind it.
So we're setting
up our data set.
And our data set
is just literally
going to be the array
that you see here.
It says give me this
array, an array of fruit.
And with that fruit array,
I'm going to select something,
I'm going to go into
the fruit array,
and I'm going or pull back the
element in the second position.
Anyone want to take a guess?
Is it going to be a raspberry,
a blackberry, a strawberry,
or a cherry at
position number two?
Everyone says-- and when I
get to this huge conference,
too, I'm like, uh-uh, berry.
Strawberry is exactly correct.
So if you worked
with arrays before,
you can get easily tripped
up with like, all right, well
is it zero-based
or is it one-based?
There's one CC.
Zero for raspberry,
blackberry, and then--
blackberry's number one,
strawberry's number two.
That's because
you're using offset.
All right, if my aliases
don't give it away.
People in the audience
are just like,
I'm just reading his queries.
You see that you can have
it as an ordinal, which
is the same thing as
offset, except you have
ordinals starting with one.
So one, two is now
blackberry instead.
So accessing array
elements, this
is like a fundamental part
of like, OK, you've got
your data into an array format.
How do you actually
get it out of it?
All right, what happens
if you did this?
I've only got four
records in there.
Well, it's going to look
for the 999th in there.
Oh, I didn't find it.
It's out of bounds, overflow.
The good thing is,
in BigQuery, you're
not charged for queries
that result in an error.
And this is super friendly.
I mean, I go to war with the
validator on a daily basis.
But honestly, it's
your best friend,
because you can
actually toggle it open,
and you can see whether or not
your query is going to execute
with an error or without.
So if you get that
green checkmark,
you're in good shape.
What other things can
you do with arrays?
You can do really cool
array aggregations.
So if you want to see how many
elements are in the array,
it's just a simple
function, array length.
And your mind will
begin to think of like,
oh, what do I want to know?
Why does array length matter?
For Carl's example
that he showed earlier,
how many articles were
published in a day, which
is the length of the array?
Do mathematical
operations-- what
if I wanted to do a little
bit more complex topics?
Here's a big one.
Exactly as Carl
mentioned before,
this is the first point where
I hit my first stumbling
block in trying to
really understand this.
I have a field that's in array.
I'm just hard coding
this array right here--
apple, pear, and plum.
And then I have a field
that's not in array.
So this is where it
gets really interesting.
So we've got repeated
string, and then we've
got all of these items
in this array associated
with this customer.
But keep in mind, this is the
massive kind of learning point,
is that this is on a
singular row still.
So this is what's called
an unflattened array.
Let's see what happens
when we flatten it.
So in order to perform general
SQL operations on this,
we need to get things into a
one element per row context.
And this is where
the syntax starts
to get the better of some
people, but it's not too bad.
So let's see what we got.
Now we're bringing back the
items, the customer names.
And this is the magical
command, is unnest.
It flattens everything out.
So while you had one row
with three items before,
we have essentially squished
it with one row per each
of the items in the array.
And you're doing what's called
a correlated cross join, which
basically says, hey, remember
when I had apple, pear,
and peach in just one Jacob?
Just associate with that with
each of the items in there.
It's not like a-- it is kind of
like a traditional cross join.
But it's not cross
joining across all
of the different
possible array values.
It's just cross joining
against just that one
that it's associated with.
And this is actually
optional syntax.
So if you ever see this
in code, that's fine.
Also, you can just
have a comma there
and that works, because that's
treated as a cross join.
So unnest is the critical part.
And the reason why--
here I like to think of
unnest as, all right, well,
unnest essentially
breaks apart my array
into one element on
each separate row.
But even more
philosophically, you
can think of this
separate array that you're
bringing in almost as
like a separate table.
And that's why you're unnesting
this after the from statement.
So typically in
SQL you say, select
a lot of stuff from
a different table,
join it on another table.
That's kind of the simple
walkthrough for any data
analyst.
You're replacing
that by saying, I
have all of my data
in this one table
but at different hierarchies.
How do I get it on
the same hierarchy?
Well, instead have doing
the joins between tables,
you're now unnesting
within that singular table.
So other cool things you
can do,Z if you can imagine,
you can find out what the order
of the element in the array
was, super useful.
And that's just simply buying
the reserve keyword offset
And then here we
just have the index
of each different
items in there,
so you could find and do things
like minimums, maximums, latest
item that's in there as well.
So this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
Carl and I have
limited time to present
all of the cool
things you can do
with nested and repeated fields.
But there's two key takeaways.
It's getting your data into
arrays is rather simple.
And working with the
syntax, once it's in arrays,
you're largely going
be working with unnest.
So when you see unnest
in people's queries,
all that means is
it's taking elements
in an array that's
in a singular row,
like five items in one
row, and having five items
be in five separate rows.
So we can do array creation.
This is saying, I have a data
set that just has strings.
We're going the other way now.
So I have one, two, and
a third row for banana.
Now we're going the reverse.
We're packing all
those into an array.
And you can't do
arrays of arrays.
I'm going to show
you something just
in a minute that has a really
cool container aspect of it.
Same queries before, but if
you wanted to do a nice order,
let's see if we can't
get apple, banana, pear.
And you can-- there you go.
Honestly, it's
much like you would
treat another different table
in there as well, same order
by works.
All right, a little
bit more complex.
What happens if I wanted
to do just a filter?
I want a filter only
to include items
that I want from one of
those particular rows.
And here's where it
gets really interesting.
So if you had
something like this,
which is what we're going
to repeat in the next query,
to get at, say I wanted to
return just the customers that
had apples in
their fruit basket,
I first need to
access that array.
Remember, accessing the arrays
involves flattening them,
squishing them into
different-- one
row per each different
element in the array.
So we need to first do that.
So at the first, you'll
see, all right, well,
this is our global list.
Let's unnest that, flatten that.
And then we can just operate
over just like normal,
because row one is apple.
Row two is banana.
Row three is pear.
We can just filter that just
like a normal SQL query.
And then we can combine
it back into an array
format at the outset.
So it's going into the array.
It's squishing it so
we can operate over it.
And then it's putting it all
back together in an array.
And you can see in the
query results here,
this returns all
of the customers
in this particular case,
the customer's baskets that
had a apple in it.
Notice that the third
row, or the third array,
returns a null or an empty set.
So keep that in mind when
you're working with arrays,
is that, if the
condition doesn't match,
in your traditional
joins, you might not
get a record returned, but
you'll get an empty set,
a null set.
OK, so that is arrays.
That's half of what
I call the magic.
So if you understand
arrays and unnesting,
that's 90% of the hard leg work.
And honestly, it took
me a decent couple
of weeks to really wrap my head
around the unnesting syntax.
But philosophically, think
about it as a separate table.
Now, Carl also mentioned
a really, really cool
other native SQL
2011 syntax data
type that's supported
by BigQuery,
and that's the
struct or structure.
Think of it like a container.
So this is where it
gets really interesting.
You have one field.
We're specifying that
it can, unlike an array,
contain different data
types within one field.
So we're going to say it's an
integer for the first field,
and it's a string
for the second field.
And we're saying
35 for this field.
We're not giving it a name yet.
And we're saying a string
of Jacob for the second one.
Any thoughts with
what's missing here?
What looks funny about this?
There's two things
that are missing.
Any thoughts?
Yeah, the names.
So we're missing not only
the name of the field--
let's execute this.
If I just ran that piece--
OK, so I'm specifying this
as 35 is going to be the age.
Jacob is going to be the name.
But also, since this
is a collection,
right, it's a collection
of these fields,
you need to give the
overall container a name.
And this is the foundation of
the nested and repeated fields,
where now I'm storing
something where
I have multiple
fields associated
with a single piece
of information,
in this particular case,
customers, where I'm
storing multiple data points.
Why is this useful?
If you're thinking in the back
of your head, that looks just
like a table that I'm bringing
in, customers that age,
customers that name, imagine
having other structs in here,
storing things like items that
are in their shopping carts
or transaction history.
Instead of having
a massive schema
with 15 different
things like you
do in the transactional
world, you bring that all
together into one
massive reporting table
through the use of structs.
Now, here is where it
gets really interesting.
Of course, you are already
familiar with arrays.
You can have arrays inside
of these containers as well.
So now we're slowly building
together our grocery example
here.
We now have what you saw before,
the age and then the name.
And then we're also
hard coding an array
to get data type in there.
So you saw this before,
repeated string.
But now it's part
of a collection
of customers in there as well.
Now, I can go the opposite
direction as well.
You can actually have an
array of struct data types.
So the combination of
using arrays and structs
is super powerful.
The two key points that
I'll leave you with
are, one, if you see a schema
that looks like this-- here,
let me pull it up.
As Carl has showed before--
actually, I'll just
jump into Hacker News.
Let me pull this up.
This is the Google
Analytics schema.
So Google dogfoods its own
schemas in the sense of,
if we're telling you
guys this is a great way
to store highly performant
data, you're going
to see that out in the wild.
So if you have Google
Analytics data,
exactly as Carl was
showing you before,
if you're looking
through your schema
and you say, OK, integer,
integer, integer, integer,
whoa, what is this record
here, that is a struct.
It's a collection.
And you see it's a
totals collection.
So much like where you might
have had a separate table
for session details about
the visitor and then session
details about the
totals for the visitor,
this is all now within
this same table.
And the easiest way you can
find that is look for data types
that have records.
And I'll show you,
just as a fun example,
you can have pretty
wide schemas now.
So I don't know if
you can see others.
There's 32 different
structs that
are available within even just
a Google Analytics schema.
And where it gets
really interesting,
if you take this
even further, you
can have structs
inside of structs.
So for Google
Analytics, how it stores
the data is global information
about the hits data at that one
level.
But what about particular pages?
OK, sure.
Hits that page,
that page passed.
You can go almost like
Inception, a couple of layers
deep there as well.
So again, this is just kind
of scratching the surface
with what we can do
with the time allotted.
But it's a super
fun concept, even
if you have your
existing data, consider
working with getting
it into arrays,
instructs, to see if there's
a performance impact.
If you're doing a lot of joins
between your transactional data
to get it in one
place, perhaps store it
on the reporting data table
side into a nested and repeated
format.
And see, instead of doing
those potentially expensive
SQL joins on your
queries, if you
can't get more performance
benefit from doing nest
and repeated.
Also, as a side plug, we're
doing a full-day boot camp
on Friday, eight hours.
So if you wanted to get
more experience working
with BigQuery, working with
data pipelines and data flows,
and we have a new lab
on the BigQuery machine
learning, which was at
the keynote a little bit
earlier today, you're welcome
to show at that as well.
But we are going to
close this session.
Carl is going to come on
back up and show you actually
how we take our Hacker
News data that we
ingested a little
bit earlier and work
with that in this format.
CARL OSIPOV: All right.
Thanks, Evan.
[APPLAUSE]
Evan, I really appreciate
it, because now I feel,
even though I am just
a program manager,
that I can do really cool stuff
with BigQuery, with nested
and repeated fields.
So let me just make sure that I
cover some of the key takeaways
from what Evan said.
And Evan can keep
me honest here.
So the first thing to remember
about arrays in BigQuery, there
are these lists that can have
zero or many values, right?
They're ordered lists of items.
But all the values in the array
must have the same data type.
You could have arrays of
integers, strings, and so on,
right, very important.
And the other point that
you need to remember, here,
when you are talking
about the arrays,
these are SQL 2011
arrays, standard arrays.
All right, so that was arrays.
Let's move forward and
talk about the structs.
So what are structs?
So structs can have many
different data types.
You can have structs with
integers, structs with strings.
You can even have structs
with arrays, right?
Remember, you cannot have
arrays inside of arrays.
But you can have arrays
inside of struts.
And if you're wondering
about the connection
here to the SQL 2011
standards, these structs
are SQL 2011 structured types.
All right, so I hope this
makes sense to Evan so far.
I think it makes sense to me.
And this is where I had my,
what I call, an Inception style
moment, when I understood
these nested and repeated
fields in BigQuery.
They're just arrays
containing structs
that may have arrays inside
of them with other structs,
with other structs, and
arrays, and so forth.
So as it's called, sometimes
it's turtles all the way down.
OK, so that was
the key takeaway.
We have these structs in arrays.
Now, let's think about
what this means in context
of this Hacker News data set.
Remember, I started
this presentation
talking about JSON data.
That looks kind of like this.
So now let's think about
it from the standpoint
of what was imported
into BigQuery
and how BigQuery actually
recognized this data
and created the schema.
So here's my Hacker News table.
And now I know from Evan that
repeated simply means an array.
And record is just a struct.
So here I have an
array of structs
that maintains these stories.
And at this point, I feel
confident from Evan's training
on these structs and arrays.
So I'm going to attempt
something extremely risky.
I'm actually going to do
some live coding right here
on stage.
EVAN JONES: Live demo.
CARL OSIPOV: Live demo,
live coding here on stage
to try to analyze
this data and try
to get some awesome results.
Because here is what I'd
like to be able to do.
Remember, with this
Hacker News data,
I'd like to be able to
go to a particular date
from Hacker News.
And let's say I want to pick
the top five most highly
uploaded articles.
And if you're wondering
why top five or top two,
as shown on the
screen, basically
here you're seeing only the
top two articles for each day
because that's how many
I could fit in the slide.
All right, so that's
what I want to get.
I want to have rows
with dates, and then
for each day, two stories.
So let's go back
to my BigQuery UI.
I'm going to query this table.
But the first
thing that I'll do,
and actually I recommend
that all of you do the same,
is switch over to something
known as a standard SQL
dialect.
So I'll disable legacy SQL,
and I'll use standard SQL
for my analysis.
So now let me go ahead
and query this table.
And here's a prepared SQL
query that I'm going to use.
So a few things to notice here.
What's going on in this query?
This first part of the from
statement is my project ID.
The HN is my data set.
Where I have the table HN 2008
was my Hacker News stories
data.
So just to make sure that
this works, let me go ahead
and just pull in the
dates from the data set,
execute the query,
and see what comes up.
And just as I expected, I simply
have a list of these dates.
So these happen to be all
the dates from December
of 2008, so pretty
straightforward.
Now, what I want to be able
to do is that, for each day,
each date from my
data set, I want
to have two
top-scoring articles.
So this means I'll have
multiple records for each date.
And what does this mean?
This means I need
to create an array.
So let's go ahead and say
I want to create an array.
And to do that,
I'll type in array.
And where is the data for
this array going to come from?
That's the important question.
Well, if I check
my schema, what I
want to have inside
of this array
are the story scores and
the story titles, OK?
So the first thing
that I need to do,
since I know it's an array
of structs, right-- repeated
means array.
Record means a struct--
let's unnest, unnest that array.
So let's unnest Stories.
And that's where the data
is going to come from,
so I'm going to use
the keyword From--
From unnest stories.
And what do I select from there?
Well, since it's a struct
inside of those stories,
let's do a select as struct.
And what I'd like to get
are the story scores.
So let's do a score
and the title, OK?
And what I'd like to do is
to give a name to this array.
So let's just go with Stories.
So the entire array of
my top-scoring articles
is going to be called Stories.
And this looks pretty good.
But remember, on my slide
it could only fit top two.
So let's add limit two, so I
can only look at the top two
articles for each day.
And let's go ahead
and do an order by,
because I want to know all
the top scoring articles
for each day.
So I'll do it order by score
in the descending order.
So I'll open up my editor.
I'll select this to run it,
do a quick sanity check.
If anybody thinks
this is broken,
Evan, keep me honest here.
So let's let it run.
All right, so it's running.
And, bam, there it is.
So that's exactly what I
expected from my slide.
I have each day in
December of 2008.
For each day, I have two
top scoring articles.
And now I can start doing
cool stuff with this.
I can put this data into
machine learning APIs
from a Google Cloud, try
to analyze sentiment.
I can use this
data to extract out
most common topics, whatever
the people at Hacker News
were discussing that day.
And the most important
thing is that it
gets me started with
analyzing this kind
of semi-structured data.
So let's recap.
What I want you
guys to think about
is what we said in the beginning
about semi-structured data.
You're never going
to have as much data
in the semi-structured
or structured camp
as our colleagues who are
working with images, videos,
sound, and so on.
But now, think about all
the semi-structured data
you have within your company
or maybe on your project.
You're probably
paying for that data.
You're storing it somewhere.
But are you getting
insights out of that data?
Are you getting
value from that data?
If not, I want you to
think about using BigQuery
to analyze that data and use
standard SQL 2011, structs
and arrays, to help
you with that analysis.
And hopefully you guys are now
excited to broaden your skill
set with SQL and actually
start doing this.
So if you are interested,
I want to reiterate what
Evan said a little bit earlier.
We have a one-day
boot camp that focuses
on taking marketing data,
Google Analytics data that uses
structs and repeated fields.
And throughout this
marketing analytics day boot
camp that we have on
Friday starting at 9:00 AM,
you'll spend a day basically
analyzing data and getting
some value out of this
marketing analytics data
for your own project.
So that's going to be at
9:00 AM in Moscone South.
And if you haven't
seen this link yet,
and if you are interested
in learning more
about doing this kind of
analysis with BigQuery,
I encourage you to sign up
for this Coursera promotion.
If you go to
Coursera.org/next18,
you can actually get one
month free subscription to use
various on-demand Coursera
classes from Google Cloud that
include topics like how
Google does machine learning,
they include topics on
using BigQuery for analysis,
and also many other topics
like Cloud architecture.
And then I'll just
leave these links here.
You can go to Google
Search and search
for things like BigQuery
Qwiklabs or BigQuery
public data sets, if
you'd like to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]